[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 14 mai une
ville racontait par ses habitants la
metteur en scène catherine laine invités
lémanique waha parler de leur vie de
leur quotidien dans la cité
saint-quentinoise ce travail sera
présenté à la maison de l'environnement
la 15e édition de la nuit des musées ce
sera le 18 mai pour l'occasion de
nombreux sites yvelinois se dévoile coup
de projecteur sur les rendez vous de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines et à
rambouillet ils étaient six à tenter
leur chance 6 pour une place samedi
dernier se tenait le tremplin yvelinois
deux premières scènes le concours de
rock en seine est de l'île de france
pour les lycées ils vont parler de leur
ville à leur manière et avec leurs
anecdotes 10 habitant de magny les
hameaux vous jouez la première pièce de
théâtre j'habite à manille une création
pensé préparé mise en scène par
catherine l'aisne nous avons assisté aux
dernières répétitions
marylène et la piscine haut et nicolas
landry j'envoie une carte ancienne de 2
many d'accord découvrir ou redécouvrir
magny les hameaux à travers une pièce de
théâtre le principe de j'habite à
manille un spectacle créé à partir du
témoignage des habitants
après une première édition à trappes
catherine laine metteur en scène est
parti à la rencontre des manic moi je
les fais témoigné je leur demande
d'abord pourquoi ils habitent cette
ville depuis combien de temps angie sont
et qu'est ce qu'ils y font
et à partir de là on essaie de composer
un spectacle à partir des anecdotes à
partir de leurs ressentis à partir de
leurs émotions
depuis novembre 2018 il travaille sur
cette représentation
dix participants des manic wade manic
oise des jeunes des adultes
tous ont quelque chose en eux de manille
j'avais envie de j'aime bien théâtre
déjà et j'avais envie de découvrir un
autre moment de théâtre c'est à dire on
raconte notre vie et on joue pas un
personnage
on a raconté l'un d'eux vide habitant de
magny les hameaux ont fait découvrir au
public lors du spectacle comme on y vit
comment on y habite
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire là bas
magnette une ville très très très
dynamique qu'il y à beaucoup de choses
et que perdre et des fois les gens ne le
savent pas toujours qu'ils lient à tout
ça moi j'y raconte donc pourquoi j'ai eu
pourquoi je nuis vivre comment ça s'est
passé et puis aussi je raconte des
petites anecdotes dont une une anecdote
sur le sur le maire de magny les hameaux
cinq sont du bisso vous vous installez
ok je baisse la musique tu dis le
buisson et tout lui sont répond en force
en venant voir ce spectacle on découvre
aussi comment vivent les habitants et
c'est important c'est un patrimoine
vivant pour moi je leur disais il ya un
centre à magny les hameaux n'y a pas de
centre mais en fait le centre c'est le
coeur et c'est un peu là dessus que j'ai
bâtie la thématique du spectacle le
coeur de magny-les-hameaux ce sont ses
habitants
prochain projet en cours d'élaboration
avec le musée de la ville j'habite
hashtags saint quentin en yvelines
des témoignages sur les douze communes
avec des comédiens et des habitants
c'est l'année de la majorité pour le
festival tout mêlé pour sa 18e édition
du chapiteau repro place à la clairière
de maule le festival a débuté le 11 mai
dernier mais il se poursuit jusqu'au
samedi 18 mai plusieurs soirées de
concerts sont programmés quelques
précisions de l'un des membres de
l'organisation
on veut quelque chose de très convivial
qui puisse surprendre tous
pin le public donc ce soit les familles
des jeunes des moins jeunes
on essaye de
le paquet sur une déco surprenante on va
avoir une soirée plutôt rock le vendredi
soir avec merzhin bourg breton qui monte
en en maturité l'a vraiment cette année
avec leur tournée nomades et on a aussi
raoul petite qui fêtent leurs 40 ans de
tournée qui font assez peu de dates et
qu'on a la chance d'accueillir sur le
festival une soirée du vendredi plutôt
rock et une soirée du samedi plutôt hip
hop swing la noblesse le 18 mai c'est la
nuit des musées les sites yvelinois sont
bien sûr rendez vous focus sur deux
d'entre eux ce soir avec le musée de la
ville de 50 ans de ville et rambouillet
pour en parler avec nous lui six
sauvageau haut responsable de l'action
culturelle et des publics du musée de la
ville et algal brillante et responsable
du patrimoine a envoyé mon jour à toutes
les deux est-ce que la nuit des musées
c'est un rendez vous que les structures
ne veulent pas rater
non pas le rater pour nous c'est un
événement important c'est le rendez vous
autour du musée qui nous permet d'avoir
une rencontre un peu différente avec le
public parce que sur une proposition en
soirée c'est toujours un programme
inédit et du coup c'est oui un événement
conquis attendu et que nous on a très
peur mais jamais je n'ai guère brillante
et qu'on a aussi un public qui ne
viendrait peut-être pas un autre moment
là donc même chose nous on s'inscrit
dans le programme depuis quelques années
maintenant ça permet de positionner
l'équipement palais du roi de rome en
tant que musée et effectivement c'est à
relire un public différent
alors elle ne cessera je parlais de
d'activités inédites
je vous y en a une c'est un atelier
photographies autour de portraits fouet
alors on a une thématique d'accrochages
des collections permanentes autour du
portrait au rez-de-chaussée et il se
trouve que l'état j'étais libre on est
en période il n'ya pas d'exposants poire
1 donc on en profite pour installer un
atelier de photos à studio photo en fait
et avec la complicité du club photo de
la mjc
les visiteurs pourront se faire tirer le
portrait presque comme dans l'assiette
au dessus de photos professionnelles
tirer le portrait à la mode de l'époque
elle est morte aujourd'hui n'ont pas
vraiment ce serait difficile d'imiter
les portraits du xviiie ou des portraits
d'indigènes fait par un peintre des
années 50 c'est ce qu'on a pas mal au
rez de chaussée
mais ils seront invités à prendre la
pose plutôt en famille plutôt en groupe
si sauvage on va se concentrer à 50 ans
de vie notamment sur les objets leur
histoire et leur impact sur nos vies ce
que c'est le thème de votre exposition
temporaire oui l'exposition objets notre
temps s'intéresse aux objets domestiques
des années 1930 à nos jours
donc la grande évolution dans dans ces
objets et qui sont marquées par
l'arrivée de l'électricité par de
l'arrivée du marketing et du design et
de cette exposition à travers un certain
nombre d'exemples d'objets issus de
différentes pièces de la maison nous
permet d'aborder ces grandes évolutions
alors c'est des objets parfois curieux
alors pas par leur utilité parce
qu'aujourd'hui on en a encore dans nos
cuisines et nos salons mais par leurs
formes et leurs couleurs
oui c'est des objets qui sont marqueur
d'une époque qui sont qui sont datés la
plupart ont été choisis sur ces critères
là certains des objets qui font date et
qu'on connaît toujours aujourd'hui mais
soit sous des formes un peu différente
soit qui ont connu une évolution très
importante
c'est le cas notamment des aspirateurs
lors on en a plusieurs et c'est vrai
qu'on on voit cette évolution formelle
et l'évolution du design en soit lorsque
des objets du quotidien qui vont donner
lieu à un spectacle aussi les équipes du
musée ont fait appel à une compagnie oui
une compagnie qui s'appelle donc cigs à
souk est une compagnie de musiciens qui
s'amuse à détourner des objets
domestiques de faits font du
détournement sonore et il est
ils les utilisent donc pour un spectacle
musical qui est très drôle et très
participatif est vraiment s'il ya une
grande générosité de ses musiciens dans
le partage avec le public
ils utilisent toutes sortes d'objets
c'est vraiment un bric à brac d'objets
détournés et il y aura donc deux
représentations de ce spectacle à 19
heures et 21 heures du roi de rome le
public plutôt faire appel à ces dons
d'enquêteurs première partie de soirée
avec souriez vous êtes lâchés et la
seconde partie de soirée avec une
enquête réalisée avec une compagnie
théâtre là aussi la compagnie la petite
main donc l'enquète s'appelle le murmure
de la berceuse
alors voilà ça ça démarre par une
découverte fortuite lors d'une
restauration d'une commode 18e un
extrait d'un journal intime et on est
plongé dans une dans une histoire un
petit peu effrayante au départ puisque
ça parle de disparition de nourrisson à
l'hôpital de rambouillet dans les années
30 d'un meurtre et donc les visiteurs
vont devoir résoudre ce mystère avant
que le scandale n'éclate
alors ça c'est les animations un peu
extraordinaire on va dire prévu pour
cette soirée mais ce que vous en
profiter aussi pour mettre en avant
j'écume votre tour votre site au musée
de la ville on retrace 50 on devine ou
palais du roi de rome on rentre dans
l'histoire de rambouillet est ce qu'il
ya des petites animations autour de ça
où on profite aussi pour dire venez d
autres jours de l'année il ya ça à voir
chez nous alors là pour la nuit des
musées nous on a vraiment axé sur la
collection sur les objets et pas sur
l'histoire du territoire
on sait effectivement tout au long de
l'année il ya d'autres événements pour
nous qui sont très importants là dessus
notamment les journées du patrimoine
c'est le cas rambouillet aussi est où là
c'est vraiment sur la partie territoire
patrimoine et valorisation du coup
locales pour la nuit des musées là on a
vraiment axée sur le design avec des
ateliers avec des visites guidées avec
ce spectacle
et puis avec aussi la participation de
partenaires des associations le
l'association des vieux pistons qui
amènera des voitures anciennes pareil
qui est aussi un pan très important du
design d'objet et puis le club des
collectionneurs des yvelines qui amènera
aussi des collections privées pour avoir
aussi d'autres facettes de ces objets
domestiques
ça me l'a même aidé du côté de
rambouillet alors il ya vraiment de
programmation qui est propre à la nuit
des musées mais c'est qu'on essaye bien
sûr de diffuser les programmes de mettre
en avant ce qui se fait en dehors pour
que ce public qui vient pour
l'exceptionnel et puis pour le côté
décalé du nocturne je prends aussi sage
tout de même qu'il existe des choses
toute l'année voilà et c'est dommage se
concentrer uniquement sur cette soirée
là comme uniquement sur les journées du
patrimoine ont plus d oc c vous l'avez
vu denis venez voir un jour la couleur
est différente la lumière est différente
merci à toutes les deux d'être venu en
plateau alors pour cette nuit des musées
vos sites ouvrent les banques je
rappelle s'agit du musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines et le palais
du roi de rome à rambouillet
d'autres sites yvelinois sont à
découvrir on fait un petit tour
d'horizon du côté de la maison triolet
aragon à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines vous
pourrez assister au vernissage de
l'exposition robert combat l'artiste
proposera d'ailleurs un concert
accompagné de lucas mentionne le muséum
en rambo litres à lui vous propose trois
rendez-vous un atelier photo une visite
libre du musée et une visite commentée
musical c'est à rambouillet envie d'une
soirée pyjama direction la maison musée
raymond devos à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse
un autre moyen de découvrir l'oeuvre du
clown poète au musée de port royal des
champs c'est un concert qui vous attend
l'ensemble les héros du jour joue
schubert à partir de 20 heures ateliers
visites guidées et visites libres seront
aussi au programme du musée de la toile
de jouer à jouy en josas
et pour finir du côté de saint germain
en laye vos talents d'enquêteur seront
attendus au musée d'archéologie jeu de
l'oie fouillis décryptage sont au
programme après on parle de musique
jouer à rock en seine comme des artistes
et groupes reconnus depuis trois ans
première scène donne sa chance à sept
groupes franciliens des groupes de
lycéens et d'adolescents s'essaient le
groupe sont actuellement sélectionné par
le festival et la région ile-de-france
lors de tremplin et pour les yvelines
cette ce week-end l usine à chapeaux à
rambouillet sujet avec nicole avec
grigoriy canale
valises les films sont terribles éviter
comme les mythes et hystérique laissez
futiles comme hiroshima radioactifs
gamma nagasaki marqué à dix avec
quelques détails anomalies bedrunes
vaisseaux spatiaux il était là pour
prendre du plaisir l'abbé drôme ces
trois jeunes âgés de 16 à 18 ans un
groupe passionné de rap français et us
du rap actuel
on rappelle en fait surtout dans la cour
du collège on aimait bien quoi et
et puis un jour on était au lycée moi
j'avais arrêté j'avais arrêté c'était
une époque où j'avais fait une pause
dans les cours et je les appelais un
jour je vais dette était chaud par un
groupe et il m'a dit oui tout de suite
et du coup on a commencé comme ça c'est
gros participer au tremplin franciliens
première scène un concours mais aussi
parfois une première scène par ces
jeunes groupes
[Musique]
j'ai toujours été attiré par le jeu de
la musique devant un peu mal de monde et
on trouvait que on a vu le tremplin sur
les réseaux sociaux font s'est dit que
c'était france était plutôt sympa de
participer jeu pour nous de mettre un
peu challenge avec le groupe
et puis après un prêt fin pour nous
notre famille et puis venir aussi
première scène est destiné aux lycéens
franciliens depuis trois ans rock en
seine et la région ile de france donne
leur chance à la jeunesse
c'est une opportunité pour des gens qui
aiment la musique qu'on monte un groupe
de voir ce que ça peut être finalement
que qu'un festival que jouer dans des
conditions professionnelles parce que ce
sera leur premier cachet et puis on va
leur apprendre cet été est ce que c'est
une feuille technique du bac live voilà
des mots qui peuvent paraître un petit
peu technique mais c'est une approche en
douceur
les sélections se déroule sur cette
scène ouverte francilienne depuis le
mois de mars
en attendant pour les vainqueurs de
jouer en août en live un rock en seine
et le groupe vainqueur de cette soirée
yvelinoise est avec nous en plateau
alors ils sont quatre oscars vater d'un
jardin nguyen williams le marchand et
mayeul augeron bonjour à tous les quatre
vous formez le groupe alpha alors
j'imagine la question la plus simple
mais j'aime et je vous êtes ravi de
cette victoire
peut-être oscars on est très content
d'eux d'avoir gagné à cette soirée
un vin plaisir et surtout enfin on
voudrait remercier avant tout une usine
à chapeaux ercanscène de nous avoir
permis d'accéder à toutes ces choses qui
nous attendent et rire me convient parce
que ça s'arrête pas là mais déjà comment
vous est venue l'idée de participer à ce
tremplin
sadi a longtemps fait qu'on parte qui on
faisait des concerts on faisait des
concerts avec une société qui ne qui
nous est joué le truc c'est qu'on
voulait quelque chose de plus sérieux
avec une meilleure organisation et donc
on a vu sur facebook une annonce qui
s'appelait ma première scène
j'en avais entendu parler par des amis
et ensuite bas oscar à un peu motivés un
peu tout les toute la troupe diba vas-y
on s'inscrit c'est comme ça que ça s'est
fait
alors comment ça s'est passé la soirée y
avait dû
stress ou pas du tout on s'est dit c'est
une occasion on la prend peut-être
williams bas il y avait forcément
beaucoup de stress parce qu on était six
groupes en tous les groupes qui avaient
plus d'expérience que nous peut-être
qu'ils avaient à la musique de qualité
du coup il y avait un certain stress un
certain jury mais au final on a gagné on
est très heureux de ça un des groupes de
qualité on le rappelle vous êtes lycéen
sur le plateau vous avez entre 17 et 19
ans mais benjamin avec ses adducteurs
zahlé pour travailler dans des
conditions quasiment professionnel c'est
ce qui vous motive et aussi c'est vrai
que c'est pas facile de gérer son rythme
de vie oil entre lycées à laon
entre les répétitions c'est ont investi
du temps et c'est ça fait du bien
d'enfin est reconnu de façon
professionnelle et que ça prenne de
l'ampleur
tout simplement il en pleure ça va être
de jouer en août
on va faire un petit historique sur le
groupe il est fondé en 2016 dans les
hauts-de-seine vous êtes tous les quatre
lycéens comme je l'aï dit est ce que
c'est une rencontre sur les bancs de
l'école comme on a dans les belles
histoires de groupes d'enfants nés de
deux écoles différentes en mission de
pasteur nom des deux saint dominique et
c'est plutôt en fait c'est né de
l'amitié entre williams et benjamins qui
ensuite williams a appelé pour dire on a
besoin d'un batteur donc j'étais là est
bonne a dit j'ai besoin d'un guitariste
et oscar était là les choses se passent
langer duel entre 17 et 19 ans mais ce
que vous avez déjà l'idée de faire
carrière dans la musique
personnellement oui d'une lancina les
prochaines dans le monde la musique
exactement après j'aimerais bien aussi
que le groupe se soit on continue la
musique avec le groupe c 1 le dernier
objectif principal je pense
bah c'est plutôt quelque chose qu'on
faisait tout pour le plaisir en fait
c'est une certaine passion la musique
avant tout mais en voyant justement que
va l'argent on a gagné justement on a la
possibilité de jouer à rock en seine le
mal du tout
ce qui pose des questions on se dit
pourquoi pas essayer au mois d'août
alors on va parler de vos influences
maintenant
ça va plutôt du côté des groupes cultes
à ses anciens si on peut dire par
rapport à votre âge oscar pourquoi ces
groupes là je pense que nous tous autour
de cette table on est d'accord pour dire
que c'est la musique qu'on écoute
quotidiennement
je pense qu'on écoute aussi tout c'est
ce qui nous permet d'avoir ces
différents styles à travers notre
musique on écoute du grunge on écoute on
écoute des des styles assez progressif
comme pink floyd les doors et je pense
que c'est ce qui a amené aujourd'hui la
création des sons qu'on fait qui sont
pourtant moderne mais avec cette
inspiration de l'époque avec aussi une
certaine inspiration des groupes des
années 90 de rap américain qui nous ont
beaucoup influencé enfin surtout moi en
tant que chanteur leader alors justement
va écouter cet extrait et on va revenir
là-dessus ans j'entendais de réaction
régie et j'expliquerai pourquoi
[Musique]
m
tu as
à l'europe parce qu'en fait nous notre
journaliste était sur place est
actuellement aux régions il avait cette
impression de rap un peu old school des
belles années 80 90 et ce qui vous
inspire aussi pour votre voix ouais
vraiment j'ai toujours été à plus tard
un fan de rap mais aussi de rock
j'ai découvert certains groupes comme
par exemple rise against the machine
c'est un groupe qui mélange justement à
ce rap américain avec le rock assez hard
et je trouve que c'est un très bon
mélange qu'on a su combler alors pour le
pour s'inscrire au tremplin fall et des
créations personnelles
est-ce que j'en avais fait des spéciales
pour le tremplin où c'est celle que vous
avez travaillé sous voulait montrer
j'imagine de la qualité on avait on
avait fait un concert de semaine avant
et donc on avait déjà toutes
propositions préparées préparer et donc
conseils pour être pris sur le pré
inscription n'a dû envoyer et vidéo de
ce concert là et donc tout était déjà
fait mais c'est vrai que la veille du la
veille de ce tremplin on était un peu
dans le ruck et on a créé une nouvelle
composition exprès je pense alors on a
tourné un peu autour du pot pour depuis
quelques minutes mais vous serez donc
sur scène en août pour rock en seine est
ce qu'il ya déjà du stress de
l'impatience comment vous êtes que j'ai
appris la victoire et d'excitation pour
l'instant et que la motivation et puis
le désir toujours de se dépasser de
faire à chaque fois meilleur concert sur
tout ça je pense alors dans la
programmation des groupes professionnels
cette fois il ya des artistes bien sûr
reconnu est-ce qu'on a que vous espérez
croisé cet été
jouer devant eux certains qui vous
inspirent m'a peut-être les groupes
cultes comme les cures parce que c'est
toujours intéressant même si c'est
peut-être pas le style de musique qu'on
écoute le plus d'avoir un visuel
ou leur avis même sur nos compositions
ou même de les voir ce serait un
privilège pour nous est ce que vous
savez déjà quand est ce que vous allez
jouer mon appareil date précise sera
communiquée début des bureaux durant les
concerts entre le 23 et 25 donc le plus
simple pour suivre pour vous voir si les
petit extrait a donné envie
rock en seine point com merci à tous les
quatre pour votre venue en plateau je le
rappelle tous les quatre le groupe
half-pipe le groupe vainqueur du
tremplin rock en seine c'était à l'usiné
à chapeaux rambouillet musique un petit
grand écart ce que leur a parlé de
d'harmonie d'orchestre quelques uns des
membres étaient invités le 30 avril
dernier l'harmonie de saint quentin
guînes fêter cette année ce week end ses
20 ans à l'occasion elle organisait son
premier festival auquel ont répondu des
harmonies saint-quentinoise et
francilienne on écoute un extrait de la
prestation de l'harmonie de montigny le
bretonneux
[Musique]
ah ah
à
avant
[Musique]
marie leczinska ce n'est peut-être pas
un nom qui vous parle et pourtant elle
est la souveraine qui a régné le plus
longtemps dans la cité royale
le château de versailles lui consacre
une exposition à travers un prisme celui
de ségou une reine des votes une
souveraine peintre une dame passionnée
par la chine des goûts personnels que
marie leczinska exprimées dans ces
appartements officielles et privées
c'est donc la première qui aménage ce
qu'on appelle les cabinets de la reine
les petits cabinets et des espaces où
elle peut se retirer pour lire pour
méditer pour effectuer des travaux
d'aiguillés pour peintres puisqu'elle
était peintre à ses heures
marie leczinska rennais quarante deux
ans sur la france le règne le plus long
à versailles
fille d'un roi déchu de pologne réfugie
en lorraine
elle devient reine après des pourparlers
il faut savoir que le royaume 15 est
d'abord fiancée une petite infante
d'espagne la fille de philippe 5 qui est
marie anne victoire de bourbon
simplement quand le roi arrive à un
certain âge il a une santé fragile et on
se dit que sa petite fiancée et bien
avant lui donner des enfants il faudrait
attendre bien des années et finalement
on va décider de renvoyer cet enfant en
espagne et on va choisir une future
reine qui soit à la fois catholique est
en âge de procréer peu mise en avant au
sein du château au profit de
marie-antoinette marie leczinska a tout
de même laissé un héritage retranscrit
ici à travers une cinquantaine d'oeuvres
et d'objets
[Musique]
le cycle de poésie ouverte à versailles
touche à sa fin pour le dernier rendez
vous c'est didier qu'un poète en
résidence et porteur du projet qui clôt
cette deuxième saison pour l'écouter
direction la bibliothèque centrale
mercredi 15 mai à 19h à versailles
toujours une exposition et metz chauvel
propose ses peintures au coeur de la
galerie saint simon originaire de
slovaquie l'artiste vit aujourd'hui à
paris et crée des toiles réaliste aux
formes géométriques ahmed s'il a revient
avec un tout nouveau spectacle après un
détour avec les plateaux de cinéma
l'humoriste renoue avec la scène ils
jouent différents à la merise de trappes
un extrait du teaser
[Musique]
quoi vous attendiez une bonne non pour
ça faut venir voir le spectacle
[Musique]
au prisme c'est une aventure troublante
qui vous attendent mathieu ville at elle
joue de sa magie mentale dans un
spectacle conférence autour du
mentalisme bande à nice
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à vivre
l'expérience cérébraux
[Musique]
au départ c'est un ouvrage de maylis de
kerangal emmanuel noble et a choisi
d'adapter réparer les vivants l'histoire
de simon et clairs liés par un choeur
qui ne veut pas cessé de battre
l'histoire d'une transplantation
le spectacle lauréat du molière 2010 est
du seul en scène est à voir les 16 et 17
mai à londres à vélizy regarder ce
qu'est soccer ce qu'il a fait bondir
vomir grossir valls est léger comme une
plume ou pesé comme une pierre ce qu'il
a étourdi ce qui l'a fait fondre l'amour
ce qu'est le coeur de simon lumbres ce
qu'il a filtré enregistré archiver
boîtes noires d'un corps de vingt ans
personne ne le sait au juste
seule une image en mouvement créé par
ultrasons pour être envoyées l'écho en
fait avoir la joie qui dilate et la
tristesse qui resserre en décrire la
dépense et l'effort l'émotion qui
précipite l'énergie prodigués pour ce
comprimé près de cent mille fois par
jour et faire circuler chaque minute
jusqu'à 5 litre de sang c'est la fin de
ce site une culture merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve mardi prochain pour
un nouveau numéro
[Musique]